Egypt's hosted former president Hosni
Mubarak has died to the age of 91
according to state television being
quoted by the Reuters news agency of
course he ruled Egypt for thirty years
let's take a live to our correspondent
jamal al shia who's followed the egypt
story the Mubarak story for a long time
here on al Jazeera English Jamal what
else do we know this comes exactly
almost nine years since Hosni Mubarak
was forced out of office by the popular
uprising dimensions their teacher
obviously he was forced out on the 11th
of February 2011 the media now
announcing that Mubarak has a past
it's there who had been rumors for many
many years about his health there had
been instances of him being admitted
into hospital and coming out however he
as was his reputation seemed formidable
even against the different illnesses
that he went through obviously they
haven't given specific details of what
led to his final demise or whether was
just a natural passing as it's expected
but what we're looking at now is a
statesman who essentially was so
controversial in the past three four
decades of Egypt's history was under his
rule that many people saw that Egypt
became a lot more corrupt it was under
his rule that the infrastructure of the
country people sodomizing so there was
the thousands of cases of hepatitis C
and other diseases that spread through
the Egyptian population or whether was
the sudden increase in police brutality
which automatically led to people taking
to the streets on January 25th those are
a lot of the things that many people
will be remembering him by there are
those who supported him obviously
however who remember him the military
general as a statesman who tried to
maybe establish some sort of new balance
in the Middle East between different
political forces but for sure his
passing is something that is going to
remind people of the situation in Egypt
as well as
obviously the political legacy that he
left behind which is one that has
allowed for the current military regime
to continue in its ruling the region and
the rest of the world I guess over the
intervening few years has adapted to the
idea that mister LCC is in charge of
Egypt as we speak right now but when we
talk about Hosni Mubarak
I mean his legacy is a multi multi
faceted concept it's not easy to sum up
what his legacy would be if only because
he was there for so very long
for sure I mean if you look at the
different massive incidents that took
place or whether it was the 1990s Gulf
War whether it was him taking office
right after the assassination of the
former President Anwar Sadat where there
was a building in issue striking that
balance between Iran on one side and
then Saudi Arabian other countries on
the other were so many different
instances where Mubarak molded for
himself and for his vision of what
Egypt's policies should be region the
sort of role but as you mentioned that
the comparison between him and Sisi
obviously will people look at that there
is complete difference and not even
domestically speaking he rather Mubarak
was one of designating specific roles to
differ so the security services had its
power influence the judiciary had this
power influence the military obviously
had the bigger stakes but there was also
a role for businessman private sector
even the Muslim Brotherhood's were
allowed to participate up to a certain
amount within the political spectrum
this is something that we've seen a huge
departure from since CeCe's rule and
probably arguably that there has been
that criticism that it was because there
was certain allowances if that's the
right word to use the Mubarak gave
although people would say was the rights
of the people but maybe those coming
from a more autocratic background would
say because of the allowances that
Mubarak
gave that's what led to people
surely been demanding for more in 2011
and that's why there has been that
departure but definitely he was somebody
who will be as controversial as he is
will leave behind a very strong legacy
not least because of those three decades
that he was in power